okay so as far as I know the zombies are
different the graphics are different the
loot distribution is different the
skills are a little different but
overall the gameplay is generally the
same
waitwait house how spicy did you make
this oh just about as spicy as you made
it for my birthday so here's the thing
about this game
there's blood moons every night what did
you make it all blowed mugs yeah
oh I'm here
you're 1.6 kilometers of whoa
considerably different it's weird
the lighting is that it looks kind of
the same but like also different in a
way that's weird yeah [ __ ] alright
let's keep the body language to a
minimum okay [ __ ] hole oh my god you're
gonna make extra work for lik C in a
sensor all of that Wow
oh my god don't you know I'm a
family-friendly Channel now at least
like imagine there's something so jumpy
this jumpy zombie Dan they really did
improve oh god it's faster oh that's not
good they can run in the day during the
day oh you're the worst
the screams commence I shall receive I
said spicy I said spicy I'm during the
day they jog alright you know you're
right oh it was being in the water bad
sure 98 percent umbrella what have I
done
hey Wade I'm almost here buddy
oh hey buddy hey I'm on the other side
of this chest this is the building we
were [ __ ] in now this is a town hall
which is not the building we're [ __ ]
in about that it's almost night what do
we do
I'm in the town hall join me how'd you
get in here I can't even find the front
door
I don't want to come I'm not coming in
I'm not gonna what happened to do a room
and there was there was oh you know it's
a BA man why you got to overreact for
everything it's real YouTube of you to
do that
I'm an overreactor dude well it's night
and we're caught out in the open with
our pants down what do you want side
there I mean God put your pants on your
pants where are they I don't see
anything what are you complaining about
1.4 kilometers away will I do for you
yes oh there's a basement what if we go
to the baseball it's like jail cells
oh there's zombies down here Oh No are
they ordered no God no this Tommy's down
there oh that's better
we don't have any mean like defenses or
weapons or literally anything I found a
shotgun I'm so slow in like me that
spawn during a Blood Moon do that spicy
I'm never gonna get to you guys right
now we will come to you Bob we're coming
to you wait we're going to Bob we're not
gonna help anyone we're gonna go or go
we're running through the Blood Moon
did you forgot to place a bedroll mark I
would do that so I don't need you okay
can I place a bedroll somewhere yeah
it's really bloody on this moon
you guys had buildings over here and
stuff yeah we're in a town hall we a
great city we were in great the desolate
wilderness yeah well you shouldn't have
done that doesn't seem like it was my
fault anyway let's get back in this city
seems like this Blood Moon is just a
bunch of hoo-ha there's a building here
I'm gonna look in okay I'm gonna go with
Mark since we're all together I would
recommend putting down big oh oh oh
since when do big hit oh my god he's
gonna give me so much stuff the health
of his corpse isn't going down I'm just
getting infinite things you're getting
infinite oh my god guys we have an
infinite boot supply oh he disappeared
damn I guess animals have a lot more
food now this is going to be a good home
for us guys this is our home now good
torch of eternal right yeah there we go
there we go is there a way to place the
torch wait what was that sound ah
there's something in here something
legless oh you bro oh you gross a new
zombie it's gross I know what is that
wait holy [ __ ] don't front when you jump
on me full half full all right I had a
gut you just found it I found a gun we
find any books too late I got in the
basement go out the basement I'll meet
you there oh this is a bootleggers
basement oh there's something oh there's
a foregrip
are we good we're good baby we're good
oh damn nice fun hell yeah
oh there's all it's a destroyed
workbench damn but there's a recipe to
have a workbench at least yeah is that
like an emergency way out or wait what
oh yeah because I'm not paying attention
now you're fine oh no this is oh no this
is this is front oh cool this is a nice
place to hold out iam mom we do not
model or on thin ice you know what fine
whatever you want to be hostile you can
be hostile but when the zombies come I'm
sorry was that with that not respecting
your wishes it was not it really was not
blender bursts in there anyone want a
blunderbuss AB lunar hoots yeah
blunderbuss it that is not what I said
Bob you done you're done let's just get
out your system by bono she's good out
of your system
I'm working on it anyway there's a
blunderbuss if someone wants it break it
break the blunderbuss know this idiot
zombie that can't oh you're creepy oh
god your face is gonna be nightmares for
me for the rest of my life what you're
doing there Bob some really useful I'm
breaking this door down yeah yeah yeah
that's great that's really cool man
man your stories are so good that's
actually what you sounded like you don't
even know what yeah I sound like you
couldn't even handle what I sound like
oh there is a working work [ __ ] guys
working working working
[Laughter]
keep doing it till I didn't spend my
smart points oh you got smart points we
all got oh no we don't have smart points
cuz I didn't finish the tutorial quest
Oh baloney sandwiches I need to place my
bedroll there's a blunderbuss down there
if you want it I hope you choke on it
nice except for when you miss and you
permanently lose your spear and it was a
nice steel spear and you spend a very
long time no life experience don't worry
I've got this yo me Bob couldn't figure
it out so I'll get it I don't know how
things work what do you mean dummy dummy
Bob he's trying to cut me deep
dummy Bob what the dummy
don't worry Bob's getting some rocks out
here alright Bob you get those rocks
good job Bob get them you're doing great
Bob thank you Bob you will you will
regret no man you just have to mock me
everything I say is so Mach worthy
please help me I'm gonna go check out a
house nearby
why go through the door when if it's
easier to cut through the very wall the
very wall the very walls are very wall
of our home
no he's exploring I'm exploring this is
better to go through the walls what is
with the lightning
yeah the random lightning was kidding me
while I was like walking over here
you know why would it do that when does
blood phone actually start 22 okay so
we're good well for now
there was nothing in this house worth
getting why did I come here
nerdy glasses Oh glasses give me
different perks they know I'm in a
basement I need to make foods you know
when a campfire in the kitchen guys we
have a problem
put it in there I'm in trouble you are a
building I'm stuck in behind a lock mall
cuz I fell down I'm gonna chew through
the gosh-darn wall oh god please tell me
the defenses are ready at the house what
defenses we might be in trouble
Oh at least it's the break-in there's uh
was that a zombie or that way or oh
that's way I got this alright [ __ ]
windows in or anything like that
wait where are you about back alright oh
you're fat you got that part mark oh
oh alright I'm out of bullets where are
you wait come inside the house with you
okay he'll kill them we kill them one at
a time wait
let's use this okay back seems to be
clear you got how you guys doing good
over here
they killed the two guys over here we
ight okay alright good good good I think
that's about another 30 or more well it
probably gonna get worse you know
I have no doubt like at night to what
happened alright I'm gonna spend my
points lucky lewd or a sexual
Tyrannosaurus
I want you heard me oh do you guys have
any is it vitamins I need antibiotics
actually did find some you're in luck I
put him in the storage downstairs yeah
oh no wait nevermind vitamins you're
screwed no there's honey I have honey
eat this honey I'm putting it in the
chest here mark you look awfully tasty
no honey honey can you guys give me your
empty jars can I be food bub
sure alright I'm gonna go try to get
this there was a safe out here I'm gonna
try to crack it manually okay here we go
chipping away at it what if I will this
even last or even here we go oh this is
doing it this is gonna take a while guys
yeah variable I say the word viable
false via Bowl you talk shows with real
people and you say vehicle yeah yeah man
because it's the proper right way to say
it
Jimmy Kimmel says it
yeah you know jammy aha me and J we go
way back you can never stop himself from
lauching in all those Saturdays and
advocates you know that's a problem it's
stupid stupid Greiner grind on us okay
[Laughter]
is [ __ ] hey yes yes I know all that I've
seen it up close
I've seen it up close this [ __ ] hey I've
made it through the safe five bits
wonder bushes all day baby
it's so confident I was gonna get food
[Laughter]
what I exactly planned no you're my
friend
no way I actually have six blunder by is
there ridiculous right now they're a
tool that I should use to harvest the
stone
this is an NBA player you can just reach
people from like eight feet away yes I
can't concur my god it's gotten to
another zip put him beat him in the face
listen is a fellow at height of an NBA
person and I can confirm this as true
maybe three of you stood on each other's
shoulders I took it as a compliment it's
funny it's marks if you got three of
youse together and three of you stood on
the other three shoulders there's some
kind of [ __ ] then maybe you'd know
what it's like to not be a tiny tiny man
yeah I hear you I hear you I hear you
oh crap axe grip my iegs know what I
sell is at me who are we doing this bit
some more I actually fell
Oh No shut up
I'm bleeding very profusely oh my
goodness I am doing so poorly there was
like nineteen thousand birds sounds
right none of you seem to have been any
concerned as with what was happening to
me not at all no babe don't babe me babe
don't you know it's my weakness forgive
you but only this why shot a bookcase in
let that be a warning to the other
material they need help with my skills
I'm too stupid I really need to find
some water guys I go so I did lucky
loser really Pat feels good to get
unloaded they're like cooking ones yes
hello hi baby
yeah uh-huh I scared myself
oh you're fast
you got fat Oh why some of these not
reloaded oh my god why are you not
reloaded please
man does the six blunderbuss method
actually not as good sounds like it'd be
perfectly good to me I don't understand
what your problem is you're right
blunderbuss has survived so many eons of
society there's a reason pirates the the
apex predators of the go on go on go on
you go under by one of their main go-to
mid to close-range I'm level five baby
are you getting all this sweet
experience I'm tossing your way within a
certain radius to be I'm not sure if
we're close to half a deck pathetic okay
apparently I am son and I am dinner
plate so I found it and Bill it's gonna
be kinda heavy bring it back you'd lug
it lug it all the way I will lug oh
sweet where the where that where that oh
my god a level game acknowledges my
amazing physique no wait that's bad
thing what it's about
it's about the very very extremely
good-looking no no no it's bad not that
way I'm like the Derek Zoolander of
seven days to die he was an idiot and so
are you alright I'm glad we got that out
they say hey wait wait am I wrong Bob am
I wrong oh you know that I'm like no
it's funny a while ago and now it's the
bits over okay not over it's never over
the last would be over don't laugh wait
I know he seems like a comedic genius
too but please come on
Mark's only mad about that because he
wants you to say that about him well I
mean it would be doesn't think I'm not
funny
he's just hurt no I'm upset at his crude
humor it's the fact that is his comedy
is bad so clever that even though it's
simple it's still hysterical no
no no way no stir yeah wait I'm coming
back with the loot baby guys I hate to
say this again but we don't have any
defenses at the house again that's fine
I found it an Vil oh wait you found it
and no no yeah right when you scream
that the Lightning's the Thunder when
you said like a cue series third take me
seriously then so you're saying I should
make some spikes or something it would
be nice all right I can make 15 would
spike traps is that enough to appease
you sir it'll do are you guys up on that
sweet honey I've got some more honey did
you get hurt again
I got hit once by a vulture and it
immediately infected me dude come on man
I I'm very susceptible oh my god I had
an aneurysm listening to you just say
that you're still here and you're
stronger for it you're welcome babe I
don't think aneurysms one of those
things that like makes you stronger
I was come on babe babe listen babe babe
I almost choked on my tongue I shouldn't
do that in my view guys my blunder by
that's not good
[Music]
you